hello everyone and welcome to a really
crazy game from round five of the 2019
isle of man chess tournament it's
world's strongest amateur Luke McShane
versus former vulture championship
challenger Fabiana Caruana before we
dive into this game and a lot of you
have requested it and for very good
reasons it's I think it's the best game
so far but you'll just have to wait and
see I have a random chess question for
you just you know to test out your vast
knowledge so here it is and best of luck
to everyone who won the 1959 candidates
tournament there we have it that's the
question if you're an older subscriber
to the channel of course you all know
the answer is Mickel tall and if maybe
your vast knowledge was a bit further
you also remember the final standings of
the 1959 candidates tournament so here
it is towel one atwood 20 out of 28 at
the followed by Paul Karis wood 18 and a
half Tigran Petrosian to follow vasily
smyslov sweaters are legal rich robert
james fisher in sixth place free recall
of stone and pal Benko in in last place
so congratulations to everyone who got
that right now let's check out the game
when the white pieces Luke opens with E
for weave e5 Knight we're 3/9 to c6
sorry about that and Knight the c3 going
for the four Knights defense Knight to
c3 with Knight the f6 by Fabi and the
Bishop to b5 the Spanish variation of
the four Knights with Bishop to d6
seems kind of odd you know you're
blocking your own Bishop here but it's
it's not a problem at some point a White
will for example capture tonight you
will recapture and then you will have
once your dark square Bishop moves
everything really to put d5 and you're
also immediately ready ready for
castling
so d3 by McShane and now just for
castles with castles by Machine and h6
by Fabi and there have been a lot of
moves played in this position like a lot
of moves any move you can think of has
been played here except the one McShane
plays he plays King - h1 so the early
attacking move getting ready to move the
knight getting great to push f4 and
start an attack against a hobby skin so
it is already as a move 7 that we have a
completely new game rook to e8 by Fabi
and now the shop captures on c6 with B
captors and c6 and not already nice to
g1 making way for this point to start
marching forward Bishop to f8 the move
we discussed now you're ready to push d5
and f4 we have a captures an f4 Bishop
captures on f4 and now five Eagles for
d5 of course the Machine doesn't want to
trade he advances the pawn pushes it to
e5 now where you're gonna go with the
knight h5 not likely as the Queen covers
that square or d7 well you could go you
could go the h7 for example but Fabi
goes for Bishop to g4 first he says I'm
gonna grab this opportunity to develop
one piece and only then will decide what
to do with the night so even if I want I
can also play nice to h5 now as the
Bishop covers it Queen to d2 and now
Knight comes to h5 and here we have rook
81 so exchange pieces are nicely
mobilized and Bobby Bobby could go for
g5 here it's a very interesting idea but
it well the ruins the pawn structure in
front of his King a little bit for
example if Bishop g3 captures captures
and then you go Bishop to g7 and you
have a very and you have a very nice
game with the bishop pair and the bishop
pair should should be enough to
compensate for your will a bit of an
advanced King's pawn structure so after
Luke 81 Fabi doesn't go for g5 first he
says okay that's that's always possible
let's go rook to b8 first now force
White's to deal with rook captures on b2
but first machine goes h3 he does he
forces Fabi now to deal with with the
bishop but Fabi of course trades on f4
first with Knight captures on f4
Queen captures on f4 and now we're back
to h5 re maneuvering this bishop over to
g6 but now Knight the d1 there is no
threat of Bishop characters followed by
Rho characters here because black has to
keep an eye on the f7 point for now so
look the before a very nice rook
lived by Fabi now activating this rook
and also pushing the Queen back with
Quinta f2 and now c5 just advancing that
pawn not allowing Queen captures on a7
we have b3 now the knight can move as
there is no more route characters on b2
and now look back the b6 from here Fabi
can use the rook for defensive and also
attacking purposes we have Knight back
to f3 and again rook BTX now doubling up
here and here you are starting to put
some pressure on the e5 pawn there is no
danger of captures and characters too
windy if I have fun because you still
have to keep an eye on the f7 points you
can just give up your light square
bishop we have night the e3 attacking
the d5 pawn and now Queen to d7 is still
defending the d5 pawn but now the f7
pawn is also guarded by the Queen so now
you can move your Bishop and maybe even
capture on f3 if needed so McShane
prevents it with g4 Bishop to g6 and now
Knight to g2 and here you can see that
McShane has everything nicely locked up
this Bishop not really doing all that
much this Bishop not doing all that much
and this night is coming to f4 and is
gonna get a very unpleasant for Fabi
with c4 there is no other active move
everything is completely locked down and
now Knight to f4 and here if you decide
to move the rook for example if you try
something like rook to e7 then Knight
captures captures and captures on e7 is
just giving too much to white it's not
something fabi's interested in doing so
first Fabi plays C captures on d3 it's
interesting because if you go for the
rook for example if Knight captures rook
captures any 6 and C captures on d3 then
black has Bishop captures on d3 and once
you move the rook Bishop to e4 and even
though you're up the exchange fabi's
bishop repair now will come alive and
it's just a just a much much better
position for Fabi so McShane doesn't go
for the rookie plays C captures on d3
the night and nicely covers the d3 pawn
and now Bishop to b4 attacking McShane's
rook we look back to d1 and now again
rook the rook 6 the e7 now FR b moves
the rook
she doesn't want to give it away you
could also play rook to 1/6 trying to
keep an eye on the a 7-point but then e
6 is very strong for example rook
captures you're gonna play Knight
capture still you have to give it up
rook captures and now you still lose the
a7 pawn so instead the Fabia goes to
rook to e7 and now in exchange as he
grabs the point Queen captures on a
seven so we've pushed back the h7 not
allowing this capture here and now Queen
back to d4 now threatening the d5 pawn
but also the bishop on b4 so you cannot
to defend both of them Fabi plays c5
gives up the d5 pawn Queen captures on
d5 now of course as McShane is up two
points he wants to trade Queens but Fabi
plays Queen to a7 he goes after the a to
pawn but McShane doesn't doesn't care he
plays Queen to c4 with with good reasons
we have Queen captures on a2 and now he
has to decide whether he wants to go
rook the a1 or the site started
attacking right away for example if
looked up a1 the Queen gets under attack
Queen B 2 and now you have Queen to d5
now keeping an eye on the a square root
2a it could be could be very dangerous
but he starts attacking right away g5
and okay we have h captures and the
Knight captures and g5 now as this
diagonal is opened up he uses this
degree maneuver the Queen Queen to 8th
check by Fabi King to g1 and now Queen
to c6 but this allows the machine to
further improve his position
d4 you cannot capture because Queen
captures Queen the Queen so rush up the
f5 now getting more control of the e6
square and now what do you play here d5
is too early if d5 Queen to h6 comes
with an attack on tonight so your pawns
are just overextended
so first Knight to d5 attacking fabric
on e7
we've looked at these 7 and not what do
you play here there's a double attack on
the night
so if rook captures here then you will
be able to capture on d5 so here McShane
went
Knight back to e3 but there was also a
very interesting move Knight to f6 check
still you're gonna recapture the bishop
so it's not a piece sacrifice if G
captures you will go d5 first push the
Queen back Queen c7 and
now recapture on f5 rook captures for
example on e5 and now Queen to g4
creates a very deadly attack for white
but it's that's too much to calculate
and McShane is a you know burning his
time really a lot I don't know the exact
time on the clock at this moment but it
was really low the idea is that if root
characters you have Knight to e4 check
you can't block with the rule because of
Knight f6 check so you have to move back
and then Queen captures here and you get
to this position that it's just it's
just beautiful for white but okay
McShane finds a a line that is almost
just as good and requires less
calculation he plays Knight to e3
there's a double attack on the Bishop
Bishop to g6 and again d5 so pushing the
Queen back Queen to c7 and now Knight to
g4 all of his pawns are nicely defended
so it's just amazing how slowly but
surely machine is improving his position
look at those beautiful nights look at
the Queen there the pawns are ready to
be put forward the rooks are incredible
and well it's just a beautiful position
with Queen to d8 attacking the knight
here and here McShane machine should
just push h4 there is nothing fob you
can do to counter this and then continue
his attack
with them with the move he decided to go
with but he decides to push ecigs right
away and it's a it's it's a mistake but
it's too complicated of a mistake even
for fog to take advantage of in time
trouble because here best for black is
queen caps or some g5 Fabi captured on
e6 if Queen captures and pawn captures
this is the best sequence for black
because now you have rook to e4
attacking the Queen also the Queen
covers the da square but it's so
complicated
for example rook to a1 you give up the
Queen rook captures and c4 and now you
play rook to e8 check King h7 and now be
chapters on c4 and now it seems like
black is a pop ween but white is getting
a queen next move but the the fact of
the matter is white is not getting a new
queen because Fabi has a Bishop to a5
and it's just I mean it's just crazy how
how complicated and beautiful this game
is especially the lines that never
happened over the
because now you have to capture the
bishop and now you have f5 you attack
the pin piece once the rook retreats to
bring your queen into the game now we
play F capture sin g4 and once the Queen
gets into the game now you have Queen to
III check and you have a perpetual rook
F - you're gonna go Queen g3 chair King
if one you're gonna capture here with
check if King you wan you're gonna go
Queen back the e3 with check and you
will always be able to keep on checking
the White King white king will not be
able to escape on the Queen side due to
the bishop covering this diagonal so
although e six is a mistake it's a
beautiful mistake and it's one that no
one would take advantage of so F
captures on e6 by Fabi with Knight
captures on e6 attacking the Queen and
now Queen to b8 and here I'm exchange of
shows what a natural attacker he is this
is move 40 so time control has been
reached
now McShane is granted additional time
on the clock and he continues the attack
with d6 it's just a beautiful move
opening up this diagonal threatening
some of the nastiest discoveries and
Fabi plays rook captures on d6 it is the
best move in the position and he has to
allow a certain amount of discoveries we
have Knight to c7 checking the King we
have rook DT 6 now blocking check are
trying to trying to give back some
material if the knight moves then you
have Queen to g3 check with a perpetual
so you can't judge it's a it's a great
position for white but you have to be
careful if you move the knight Queens
III check ensures the Fabia perpetual so
rook the d7 by Luke this is a beautiful
defending the knight adding another
attacker and asking Fabi what do you do
here Fabi immediately on pins he plays
King to h8 and here this is the the
celebrated position that I mean we
already saw how how beautiful this game
is but now feel free to pause the video
and try to find the winning move for
McShane in this position while I give
you a couple of seconds for those of you
who were able to do it I just don't
believe you as it's yeah we could make a
separate video just discussing this idea
but if you have founded all the lines
then you
or you're probably a hidden 2,800 player
but for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's actually nice to the
f6 and it seems the logical now that you
see it of course you now see Queen to h4
but roblox Queen to h7 mate it's very
simple right well not really it's it's
extremely complicated well you have to
first see what happens if rook captures
for example if rook captures well or if
G captures either way but let's let's
check out the G captures first if you
capture with this then it's Queen to h4
check King to g8 and now Queen to h6
threatening mate here and the once you
block mate we have Bishop to f7 now
covering the g7 square now you play rook
captures on f7 King captures and queen
to h7 check and now the point is after
you move the King King f8 now comes the
Knight captures on e6 with check there
is no move the King hasn't over to go
you have to capture the night and once
the rook captures Queen h8 check King g7
and you pick up black screen on b8 Queen
captures on b8 and you have a completely
winning position so after Knight to f6 G
captures doesn't doesn't work what about
rook captures on f6 it's similar Queen
to h4 check butcher blocks Bishop to h7
and the now rook captures on f6 black
cannot recapture because the rook would
cover the h7 square and queen to h7 will
be checkmate so look the g8 and now you
just move the rule back rook to f8 and
you get this position where black is
pretty much without a move the Queen has
troubles getting into the game you have
some ideas like maybe rogue d5 look to
h5 it's it's not that simple as for
example if you try this idea Queen will
capture the night and if rook h5 you put
the g6 pawn the Queen from c7 will be
guarding the de Bishop but it's it's an
overwhelming position for white so
that's what happens if Knight to f6 what
happens if black ignores you and it
doesn't capture it at all there's a rook
to e4 really complicated move offering
the exchange attacking whites Queen and
anything is possible here but here
McShane has Knight captures on e8 I mean
even even you he did did reach them time
to control he had time but it's just
it's just disgusting for example you
capture the Queen rook
the ff8 check now you will go King to h7
and mount Knight to f6 check you cannot
capture due to the pin here King to h6
and now Knight back to gh app you pull
the King back in g5 knight c6 check at
any point you can just grab blacks Queen
doesn't really matter King to h4 or
wherever rook captures here and you end
up with this line being up a whole rook
of course in a completely winning
position so after King to h8 Knight to
f6 the the immortal elusive move but
McShane misses it and he plays Queen to
f4 so all it's the second best move
you're threatening Knight captures on e6
just picking up a rock if black trades
Queens you also capture the Queen so
black cannot recapture the night and if
you capture the night with the roof also
just Queen captures Queen is in the
position but it allows Fabi to wiggle
out we have Queen to b6 now Fabi gives
up to the exchange he's very happy that
he can give him the exchange to continue
the game with Knight captures Queen
captures and now rook the d6 attacking
the Queen also the bishop is behind the
Queen we have Queen to f4
now Fabi wants to trade Queens and try
to hold this end game being down the
exchange Queen to g5 attacking the
bishop twice and now King to h7
defending with Queen to h4 with check
King back to g8 and now Queen to g3 not
allowing any ideas to start checking the
the white king and also if the knight
moves you also have a double attack on
the bishop here so King to h7 Fabio
repeats he wants to defend his bishop
and now Knight to f2 blocking this
diagonal not allow any checks also
attacking the Queen with Queen to c2 you
have to keep an eye on the bishop here
and now Knight to d3 a very interesting
idea trying to trying to go into a 40
endgame with the Bishop captures on d3
but Fabi plays a different line Fabi
plays Bishop to e4 instead he doesn't
want to go into the endgame now and now
Queen to g5 a very strong move
threatening Queen to h5 check followed
by Queen captures rook here with check
so Queen e2 you have to guard the h5
Square and now once again feel free to
pause the video this one's a little
easier and try to find the winning move
for white well I give you a couple of
seconds
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations unsporting move with the
night back as well when when when it's
possible it is the strongest move and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
a show it's nice to see one and here
Black has no way of keeping control of
the h5 square
Fabi is without a move here whatever you
play queen h5 chair picks up the rope
with check is the game over or you can
just trade everything with queen g2 and
well captures captures captures and you
are up a whole rook though pretty much a
pointless idea so nice to see one
winning on the spot but machine misses
it he plays nice captures on before we
have C capture Sun before and the now
rook to d2 pushing the Queen back even
though both of them reach time control
McShane is again very very low on the
clock we have Queen back to a6 again
now if if this check happens then the
Queen can block and if you capture the
rube then the black Queen captures the
rook on d2 so it's not a problem
Queen to h5 check we have Queen to h6
now the idea we discussed but now Queen
captures on h6 instead here McShane goes
for the endgame with King captures on h6
and rook e1 hoping for rookie duty to
win the material here we have looked he
5 King to h2 not allowing Ruby g5 to
come with the check so King h2 and now
rook the d5 here Bobby we was out again
offers the trade rook captures Bishop
captures and rook to e3 so here we have
an endgame
McShane still at the exchange but it
will be very hard as when the King joins
the game Bishop Bishop from east 6 will
be constantly targeting both of
McShane's pawns but ok g5
with King to g3 improving the position
of the King and King to g6 King to f2
and now comes King to f5 Fabi brings the
King even deeper into the position we
have g3 for the rook and now Bishop to
e6
King to e 2 and now Russia back to d5
constantly keeping an eye on this pawn
here and the King is guarding this point
with King to d2 and now Russia back the
e6 with rook to f3 check King to e5 as
you see the bishop is
constantly attacking these two pawns
Ruki three check we've kinked the f6 and
the now King to see - Bishop - f5 check
the King cannot cross here as the pawn
in the bishop create a wall for the
White King so there's no crossing here
with King to c1 and now Bishop to e6
again just keeping an eye on both pawns
with King daddy - and now the show back
to d5 with King - see - and now Bishop
back to e6
Bobby is of course very happy with the
draw here there's nothing to do other
than that King back to beat you and now
Bishop the f5 we've looked the g3 Bishop
to e6 and now rook back to d3 with King
to e5 and then out comes rook to e3 with
Czech king of six and now finally
McShane as he sees that there's no way
of breaking through plays rook to e4 he
allows this capture and he goes for this
capture as well a bit stronger perhaps
would have been king to c1 trying to go
get this king - king said as you can
always capture the before pawn there's
no rush in doing that but McShane
decides to pick it up right away
now g4 Bobby starts pushing this passed
pawn rook to e4 and now g3 weave King to
c3 King to f5 attacking the rook rook e1
and now kinked f4 with b4 by McShane
team to f3 and now b5 King to have two
attacking the rook and now King to d2
just defending it will G - and now be 6
by McShane and of course now you don't
of course trade everything and allow b7
you have to cover the light square b7
square with the bishop and here McShane
just playbook to e2 and it was in this
position that they agree to a draw as
there is nothing to do here it's it's
just pointless you will constantly have
to keep an eye on this pawn and there is
no way to make any progress here just
you know the King will hide and if you
want to prevent the point from queening
you will have to constantly keep
checking and pinning and there's no way
your pawn will ever across the b7 square
so here McShane and corona agreed to a
draw in an
well in a ruined immortal game for
McShane and well it's just a very tough
break but you know there are people who
will play Knight of six check but those
are people who would not get who would
not get a high rating in chess you know
over the course of time because if you
can't calculate everything yes you're
gonna play it but unless you're the next
to me hotel you know you just don't know
everything you have to calculate and if
you play it without calculating you will
most likely lose games especially
against 2800 players like Caruana so it
was a beautiful move but of course
McShane saw it machine and definitely
saw it and he was thinking about it but
seeing it and playing against Khurana
are two very different things
yeah the tough break and a missed
opportunity for machine not only to beat
Khurana but also to take Italy in the
tournament and now the standings are I
will put a link in the description below
for you to check out the standings there
are 150 players I can't mention all of
them but you will be able to click on
the link and check out the standings for
yourself but so far in the lead with
with four points I believe on how
Fabiana Kirwan Alec McShane Vladimir
Faris save Alexander Grisha
Alexei Shiro and Parham Mac Sulu so we
will see what happens in round six I
would like to thank James Dunn
prathamesh Mahajan Michael Shaw Nicholas
sauce Rojas and Proctor mining for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the Addis very nice Swiss
tournament the Isle of Man chess
tournament checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and of course whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day